you've probably heard of the drew leak
the most competitive summer basketball
league in the world
rumors swirl all week about select nba
stars who might be shown up first it was
d rose then it was cp3
harden and then caleb it landed on kevin
durant a three-time nba scoring champion
the nba summer league is not the best
run during the nba offseason and it's
not even close each summer a select
group of nba stars head down to south
central los angeles to compete in a
jam-packed high school gym against some
of the most talented amateurs in the
world each year the drew gets bigger and
the competition better
east 120th in compton ave you have to
see it to believe it gentlemen we
interrupt this program to bring you
important news
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
this is
you